[Music]
your husband's here to see you
what happened how did I get here
Jennifer you were in an accident and you
hit your head you don't remember me do
you
no you need I'm Russell it's really nice
to meet you
this is really her house it's been in
family for a while so quiet better be
nearest neighbors over a mile away Oh am
i I was wondering if your wife would
come down to the station tomorrow at
11:00 to talk about the accident
wait tomorrow at 11:00 I overheard John
said on the phone I was worth calling
you know wondering when I was coming
back
[Music]
something I'm gonna head into town today
you gonna be okay I'll be fine I feel
like I just need to take a look around
maybe something will trigger memory
don't want to do it since Jennifer had
no ID
how did Russell prove he was her husband
it says here that he showed some family
photos
Jennifer in Brussels is the happy couple
right there
if that's Russell who's that
what did you do to my husband
this was no accident
all I ever wanted for you to love me
[Music]
[Music]